back now on cbs mornings at 7 30 and the
war in ukraine is bringing back cold war
memories for millions of americans
including a deep fear of a potential
nuclear war in fact a recent cbs news
poll found that 70 percent of american
adults worried that russia's invasion
could at some point involve a mushroom
cloud like the ones you've been seeing
behind me
and the rhetoric from russia's leaders
has only poured gasoline on those
concerns in a not so veiled threat
president vladimir putin warned this
week they have all the weapons they need
to respond if other countries get
involved in the fighting in response
president biden said yesterday it's
irresponsible for russian leaders to
make idle comments about nuclear weapons
so unfortunately now seems to be like a
very good time to think about what a
nuclear war might actually look like and
whether our country would be prepared
on a gloomy spring day just across the
river from new york city we spent some
time recently imagining the unimaginable
if a nuclear device were to detonate
right there
what would it look like from where we're
standing the fireball itself would be
bigger than the empire state building
considerably historian alex wellerstein
has spent a career studying scenarios
like this one a few seconds later you
would feel a shock wave hit you you
would feel a heat on your face it would
be an awe inspiring sight it would be
terrifying but like nothing else you
would ever see
in this world test explosions caught on
camera decades ago allow us to actually
see just what a nuclear blast would look
like the result of an uncontrolled chain
reaction splitting and fusing atoms and
releasing an energy locked inside
billions of years ago
by exploding stars but to demonstrate
what a nuclear blast would actually do
to a city wellerstein a professor at the
stevens institute of technology
developed a grim tool a website called
nuke map on which people can simulate a
detonation anywhere in the world let's
put it around times square and as in
real life it begins with just the push
of a button okay all right let's hit the
button let's hit the button
oh man and look at the fatalities
there's a sort of zone that's about here
which is pretty hopeless no matter what
that's with a bomb like the one that
struck hiroshima a so-called tactical
weapon small by today's standards
when we simulated larger more modern
bombs we went from 15 kilotons now to
800 kilotons we saw how a single blast
could cause heavy damage throughout an
entire metropolitan region killing
hundreds of thousands of people wow with
winds carrying radioactive particles
even further these are areas where if
you're
not taking shelter several hours after
the bomb you could get enough radiation
to die you could get enough radiation to
get significantly sick the atomic bomb
explodes
there was a time when americans prepared
for such an attack first you duck and
then you cover in the 1950s and 60s
school children did drills to help
survive a blast and a public campaign
educated americans on surviving the
fallout kicked up by the bombs drifting
back to earth the amount of dust
on my finger could kill a man in a
matter of days
civil defense teams spent hundreds of
millions of dollars building and
stockpiling fallout shelters all across
the u.s on your way down you'll see
fallout shelter signs but a visit to the
basement of a public library in passaic
new jersey
reveals just how far this threat has
fallen into the very back of our minds
and some of what we have over here are
supplies this is some of the supplies
that were in this basement that are
still intact in a space at one time
designed to shelter up to 90 people
decades of dust has settled over the
medicine and food which has long since
expired anyway
oh god it really smells like a shoe
that's amazing and building supervisor
gary savatoriello says there are no
plans for replenishment have you in your
10 years here met anybody who came from
the government to check on any of this
no no not my 10 years instead this
one-time fallout shelter like so many
others has turned back into an everyday
storage space though the signs are still
up no one ever took him down
russia's invasion of ukraine however has
suddenly resurfaced our worries about
nuclear war
are you getting more signs of concern
from the general public about nuclear
war
oh absolutely at george washington
university professor sharon squasani has
been warning for years about the risk of
nuclear conflict
the lessons of the cold war seem to have
been forgotten the number of nuclear
weapons has decreased dramatically since
the cold war but still russia and the
u.s each have more than fifteen hundred
weapons deployed and ready to fire
and squasani fears that could eventually
happen either by accident or intentional
attack in a conflict like the war in
ukraine and we know from russian
doctrine that they have a plan or
they've been thinking about using
nuclear weapons to escalate the war to
stop it or de-escalate it what is
escalating in order to de-escalate to
signal to the enemy that
you know all bets are off we are really
serious about this war and you need to
back off the big question then is what
would happen after that initial attack
the world would recoil in horror and i'm
sure there would be a lot of voices
demanding
for
some kind of similar action
but do you really want to trigger
the third world war a third nuclear war
the question is whether vladimir putin
does i don't think
that vladimir putin wants to tangle with
nato i don't think he wants to tangle
with the u.s but i also think that we've
been misreading him for quite a while
the truth is there is very little
standing in the way of an all-out
nuclear war
the only thing that really stands is
that
it is not really in the interests of our
enemies to have that happen to them
either so even though nuclear weapons
haven't been used in battle since 1945
the threat they posed never really went
away
something that probably should be on our
minds we have a long list of stuff to
worry about but i think they should be
on the list i'm not saying they should
be the top of the list all the time but
i think if they were on the list you
might get a somewhat different world as
a result you think that should be true
even after hopefully the war resolves in
some way and tensions decline future
problems are brewing i guarantee it
oh boy it's definitely on my list that's
troubling yeah just the fact that we
even have to put it on the list i know
what's crazy
go ahead so if you're in times square
and you live miles away
miles away you die because you're you're
incinerated you gail off a weapon
detonated here
you would die in that initial explosion
probably from the fire uh or the the
shock wave in brooklyn i'd be hurt by
shrapnel and then uh probably exposed to
a lot of radiation what about harlem uh
harlem would get radiation uh it's all
depending on the size of the weapon
what's really wild about this is the
only thing that deters russia from
detonating a weapon is them believing
that we're crazy enough to fire back
right right so we called mutually
assured destruction yeah
yeah right the acronym is appropriate
yes it's insane it really is i remember
those bomb shelters in my school um as a
little yeah that was fascinating very
very scary